oh boy you sure got to climb a lot of
steps to get up that capital here in
North Carolina but I wanted what that
drogyn is little bill the steps is doing
there oh I'm just a bill
good I've liked the beach hill and I'm
sitting here on Capitol Hill well I am
all dolled up and I'm feeling really
pretty but I gotta take a leak and I'd
like to do it sit oh can I use a ladies
room where pray that I will what to do
I'm still just a bill
chief fell people sure are making a big
fuss over boys using the ladies bathroom
oh I'm not aboard and that's because
those laws are hate speech head speech
yes see transgenders want to use
whatever bathroom they feel like but
some businesses and organizations
complained and said they didn't want
grown men next to little girls in public
stalls so the state legislature passed
laws requiring that people use the
bathroom based on the gender they're
bored with you mean like if you have a
penis or a vagina no see because genders
non-binary take me
I consider myself gender fluid gender
fluid yes see that means I can change my
gender on any given day based on how I
feel and if people questionary I just
call the ACLU Wow and you can
biologically function as either gender
no but to even point that out is HP oh
yeah
yeah I'm just a bill but I hope to be
Jill and if I don't be I'm gonna be ill
but now I'm stuck with no access as a
sit here and wait while celebrities and
tumblr blogs yell and debate oh man I
need to drop or do
and pray that I will but today I was
still just a bill listen to those people
arguing is that all over your gender
identity bill Jill Jill yeah and I'm one
of the lucky ones most transsexuals
never even make it this far I hope they
let me use whatever bathroom I wanna I
made I died yeah because the trend is
suicide rate so high
really statistically observable I'm
shockingly so and it doesn't get any
better even if we go through with the
surgery so barely even without your
penis they still won't let you use the
ladies room oh I still have a penis an
overwhelming majority of transgenders
never go through with the full
transition oh no oh yeah I'm just uh
bill but I'd like to beat you and I'm
demanding bathroom access at will oh I'm
coming for your shower
where I will torture Jane I am no longer
bill chisel if you want to be a woman so
bad
why don't most transgenders just go
through with the surgery because my sex
organs would forever be non-functional
my body would even try and close it as a
womb G so you'll never go through it the
sex change operation and if they can
change from day to day how do we know
who's sincere you'll just have to take
their word for it or risk getting sued
sounds a whole lot more confusing than
basic biology biology is just a social
construct why should I have to conform
it's everybody else who should change
oh I hope and pray that they will but
today I'm still just a bill
congratulations bill you can use
whatever bathroom you want and I can
keep my you can keep your cup oh yeah
hey many of you or how about subscribing
by clicking the button below
it's free or you can watch one of these
videos playing in a box they involve
transgenders firearms on BuzzFeed so you
know they'll be bad